ils sont ici ils sont là les
influenceurs ans par les matches y
partent à la conquête de l'amérique du
nord
et moi si c'est un produit qui est
mignon qui est bon et qui va aller
chercher en fait une nouvelle clientèle
et répondre aux nouveaux besoins des
clients qui veulent manger plus des
produits ethniques en fait goûter des
choses différents et voyager dans
l'assiette petite boule de pâte de riz
d'environ 35 grammes le mochi qui fait
tourner les têtes ces jours ci contient
en son centre de la crème glacée natrel
et le choix du président viennent tout
juste de lancer leurs gammes de mode
chic ou les simples c'est le libre
service pour une dizaine de saveur ils
servent eux-mêmes ils font leur
assortiment donc qu'ils peuvent les
mettre sur une brochette pour les manger
tout de suite vous faire un assortiment
qui les ramener à la maison ça se mange
vraiment avec les doigts son cornet sans
cuillère sans rien qu'est ce qui
caractérise un bon moi je suis selon
vous pour moi c'est la pâte de riz en
fait la texture le goût et surtout la
pâte de riz la pâte de riz c'est ça va
être un petit peu élastique est assez
épaisse en fait le moins bon moshi
parfois la crème glacée va se confondre
avec la pâte de riz alors dans le bon
mot chien on sent vraiment les deux
textures en fait entre la pâte de riz et
la crème glacée
les matchs se décline aussi farsi par
exemple de sésame de chocolat ou encore
de fèves rouges une tradition japon
depuis plus de 2000 ans le mochi a une
symbolique religieuse et sert
d'offrandes aux nouvelles on dit que
c'est mon pti c'est quelque chose sacrée
ont décollé il y à là du qui vit dans
l'âme aussi séduit c'était important
pour asia tic comme patrice part donc
pour l'avancée de vie c'est vraiment
important pour la vie c'est pour ça on
dit qu'il y à l'adulte lui et mme otis
et un signification de toutes là oui da
chasse le mode traditionnel est à la
base une boule formé avec une patte de
vie colle cette partie façonné en
martelant de manière spectaculaire le
riz collant cuit jusqu'à l'obtention de
la texture désirée mais aujourd'hui un
appareil permet 40 minutes d'obtenir un
bon résultat
monti mots qui motive mon type menti
remy m'annonçait d'iphone menti une
boule de pâte de fèves rouges sucré au
centre la pâte hazuki scénic scénic au
caire massa mais comme ça oui oui oui un
beau contraste avec la barbe de faire la
part des choses
une autre variante et le qui n'a comme
hot chip mochis nature enrobé de poudre
de fèves de soya rôti nom est moins sûr
une première dette je dirais non
mais ajoute un peu la rage id la feuille
de saooti c'est les enfants aiment ça
maintenant y sauver mon outil ils sont
démentis o'casey isobe il sauver sa vue
le bord de la mer
j'avais trop honte et dans le soya est
ce que le hockey est simplement vous
allez emballé avec désert
finalement le chef prépare le aux
chiroux qu'au mode chic
il s'agit de bouillon de fèves rouges
sucré et de mochis nature mises en garde
ici ne prenez pas trop grosse bouchée
pour éviter de vous étouffer a du
mondial oui c'est ça c'est un gros mais
oui ici normalement les gens pensent
quelque chose du beausset jesse le goût
au japon toujours où on a considéré
trois choses le groupe
ça va à l'oma et chose de plus important
c'est la texture texture mois ci disons
la texture du nouvel sucrées ou salées
chaud ou glacés les mochis une gâterie
japonaise à découvrir
[Musique]